hey everybody welcome to rollback where
we serve up the very best of our
pre-video episodes to the youtube
algorithm for the very first time
and when considering the best my mind
instantly returns to episode 269 from
january of 2017
with travis barker
travis is a musician an entrepreneur and
of course the drummer for the
influential multi-platinum punk rock
band blink 182
in addition he's recently been making
headlines once again for producing and
collaborating with a myriad of artists
such as machine gun kelly avro levine
willow smith and many many others
in addition to just being incredibly
talented skilled accomplished and one of
the most prolific rock drummers in the
world travis is just a really sweet guy
with a fascinating backstory so today we
get into that story it's a conversation
about his path to mastery
it's about the harrowing plane crash
that nearly killed him and his traumatic
road to recovery we talk about sobriety
balancing his rock star life with
parenting
talk about entrepreneurship fitness and
just tons more
this is one of my favorite conversations
in the history of the show i think
you're going to dig it
so please make sure to hit that
subscribe button and with that i give
you
travis barker
i'm really super uh
inspired by your story and there's a lot
of points of intersection that we can
explore and i'm just pumped to be able
to uh hijack you and force you to answer
my questions cool i'm game i'm game you
know i was wrapping my head around
around kind of you know what you're
about and who you are and and i think
something that's super interesting about
you know your the musical uh aspect of
what you do is that
obviously you're known as a drummer
you're very prolific talented uh
accomplished drummer
but it's really a lot more than that
because you're sort of persona or
you know i hate that word brand but like
you know who you are is really
much larger than that like you have this
very kind of creative entrepreneurial
approach to what you do
that allows you to kind of
expand outside like the four walls of a
band and
has allowed you to like collaborate with
all these amazing musicians across all
different genres as well as you know get
involved in all different types of
businesses like it's a very dynamic
approach to
your profession and your career right is
that accurate yeah i mean
i've i've kind of along the way of
playing music as a symptom of playing
music
i've been able to express myself and be
um
successful in a couple different
creative outlets which has been just
amazing never
never with the intention to make money
or to be successful it was always like
well i love doing this
and
if i could make it make sense to where i
don't lose money doing it cool and it
could just be a hobby and those hobbies
have turned into i guess what you call
business now right so it's so it's
really leading with your heart leading
with your gut leading with your instinct
yeah always i mean anything i'm involved
with is because i absolutely love it
i i've learned like i've learned trust
the trust the gut like if i if my if my
my gut my intuition tells me no it's a
no where did you learn that like where
does that come from
i feel like i learned the hard way
a little bit you know there's there's
certain there's big there's
big pivotal decisions in my life
where um
i've made the wrong decision like making
the making the decision because of the
paycheck or as opposed to the the
creative
uh fulfillment of it yeah or i guess
just i when i look back at times i was
like whoa i knew that didn't feel right
and i still went ahead and did it uh-huh
and i just go why you know and but
everything happens for a reason and i
and i believe in that that saying uh win
or learn you know and you know a mistake
isn't a mistake you learn from it and
and i and now i'm here to say you know
like i do trust my gut 110
it seems that
you know to me and kind of reviewing
your story and knowing a little bit
about you know where you came from that
a lot of it tracks back to
you know something your mom told you you
know shortly before she passed i mean
she passed she you were pretty young
right like just before you started high
school yeah it was a day before high
school uh-huh
and what it what what was it that she
said to you she said no matter what
follow your dreams and play the drums
like don't stop playing like that's the
one thing i think that's the one thing
like i think as a child and i've seen it
even with my own kids it's like if you
give them the option that they don't
have to do anything they're not gonna do
anything right
so for me
they were very disciplined in like
you've gotta practice
x amount of hours a day you've gotta
you gotta be productive you've gotta put
time in with you know your instrument
which was the drums for me i mean i sang
with like i sang in madrigals and in
school and piano but nothing got me like
the drums did
you know there was a portion of my life
where i was like 14 15 and i thought i
wanted to be a professional skateboarder
but i was way way better at playing
drums than skateboarding
so
if
my mother and father wouldn't have made
me practice i would have when she died
there would have been nothing for her to
say do that you know and she
you know i started just banging on
things at the age of four and she's like
i think he's a drummer right so it's
just the pots and pans kind of thing
right yeah like pots and pans and but
she showed up to support that like he
got you some lessons and a kit and all
that kind of stuff yeah she got me a
teacher at the age of four that taught
me how to read and i was really good at
sight reading i was really good at just
reading music in general i would go to
drum competitions and there were sight
reading competitions where you know i
was like five or six and they'd put a
sheet of music ahead of you you've never
seen in front of you and you just
have to kill it you know you have to go
there and do it and i was really good at
sight reading and then so you picked up
learning how to read music at how old
yeah five and six years ago wow yeah
that's almost like some crazy past life
thing right like you were able to just
tap right into it like that yeah it was
weird and no one played music in my
family nobody was just like i just
understood note value really young and i
think it was a combination of that and
they just pushed it on me really young
like if you're gonna do this learn it
right and then once i learned how to
read it was really no one really could
teach you how to play rock and roll or
teach you how to play to your favorite
hip-hop groups uh you know i had that
same teacher that taught me when i was a
kid named ed will he just taught me jazz
basics like learn how to read charts
and then
i just listen to everything so after
that it's just you know whatever
whatever is like getting you excited and
then playing it over and over and over
again and trying to mimic it yeah just
listening to what i loved and some of it
would be like program drums that a drum
machine it was an sb 1200 you know right
it was a mpc and i would copy those
drums from from beastie boy records or
public enemy records
so that was uh
i was just exposed to everything i was a
really happily confused kid
in a time where
in that in that time i think you either
listen to
punk rock or you listen to hip hop or
you were a goth kid or you or whatever i
was confused and i was so
thrilled with being confused and liking
everything
so southern california right like
fontana area and we're talking about
like late 1970s yeah i was born in 75
uh-huh right so early 80s maybe yeah so
then who so
so who were your guys like who were the
who were the big influences drummers or
just drummers and bands
drummers in bands is that what you said
yeah um
stuart copeland
for sure uh dennis chambers he was like
a fusion drummer right uh steve gad
buddy rich
a lot of jazz guys really for me yeah
yeah yeah um
carter buford it's interesting with the
jazz right it makes me think of whiplash
yeah when you watch that do you tap into
that emotionally like do you see
yourself in that character at all oh so
many so many
so many similarities
for me it was really
when when i was in when i joined jazz
band in high school my mom had just
passed away
i was really
uh
just shut down i really closed myself
off from everything and everyone
and i just focused on music it was weird
just her words resonated with me and i
just
something told me to just
be obsessed with drums like well it's a
beautiful gift that she gave you yeah
the permission
to
chase your dream i mean what more you
know what more do you want from a parent
right and yeah their belief and their
conviction that you can do it like
that's just
you know
it's a beautiful way for her to pass and
and to you know
sort of bequeath that to you yeah and
then for you to really be able to hear
it and take that and run with it yeah
especially in a time where you couldn't
go i remember going to my counselors i
think they start talking to you in 11th
grade and they're like what are you
going to do
you're going to go to college and i was
like
my dad and my family we don't have money
for college and
frankly i didn't what did what did uh
what'd your dad do
he worked at kaiser steel he was a steel
worker um
and we just we didn't have a ton of
money we were you know we we got by and
for me and i didn't have the grades once
my mom died i was really just getting by
all i was focused on was drums you're
like a skater stoner kid or what kind of
like what crowd were you hanging in not
by that time by the time well i think
when my mom passed away i stopped
skateboarding it was kind of like i
really like laser eye focus on drumming
just
something clicked immediately
uh and that's all like that's all i
focused on and when i i remember having
those conversations were like are you
gonna go to college what are you gonna
major and i was like i'm gonna be a
professional drummer and they're like
what are you talking about i was like i
just want a tour that's all i want to do
i don't care if i'm poor as long as i
have enough money to eat and sleep
somewhere
that's my only goal you know and i i
almost felt guilty at that point to
dream of anything more significant than
that it was just like
do what i love somehow find a way to get
paid for it
and that's it and they
just counselor after counselor would
laugh at me and just be like you
are an idiot yeah you know and go back
to your high school to see any of those
guys nah i've donated some like musical
instruments and stuff i don't think any
of the same you know faculty is there
but uh
but that was almost even more motivation
to go harder and just be like there is
you know i started to learn there was no
path to get to where i want to go
i have to create it and i just i can't i
can't take i can't take no for an answer
i just gotta be obsessed yeah you gotta
want it you have to be obsessed and you
know the the part the piece i think
that's missing from what you just
explained is
is having like an incredible work ethic
you know which i think is a
characteristic of of you know your
success like you work your ass off man
you practice like crazy right that
obsession translated into action yeah
and which it was funny you know my
father wasn't involved with music
but he was a steel worker and there
wasn't even when he got home he would be
building a fence or he built our house
with his own two hands you know
it was i saw his work ethic and it just
i applied it to what i do and what i
love and i i still ever you know my
friends go like dude what are you doing
you work like you're broke
and i'm like nah i work like i never
wanted to go away and i and i'm never
even with playing the drums as long as i
have i'm still learning and
i make the choice to still be learning
how do you keep it fresh though i mean
it would be very easy to just get soft
after all the success and just knowing
like yeah i can pull it off like i don't
have to i don't have to sweat it i guess
being in competition with myself just
being better than i was yesterday and
and where does that drive come from do
you think like that's just nate just
wanting to be great
wanting to keep learning wanting to take
it a step further the days where i'm
like
gosh i don't even know what i'm going to
practice today it never happens you know
i sit down i put a metronome on i put a
timer down i usually practice for an
hour at a time sometimes i'll do
two to three hours a day and i'll just
you know uh something will click and
i'll be like i've never thought of that
before this pattern that i've done a
million times i've never thought about
applying it to
a different drum or
or maybe some days i'm just working on
speed or some days
you know you can be right or left-handed
with drumming so some days i'll just
focus on
playing left-handed not because just
just just to do it in case of an
emergency
i'll be able to pull it off live and and
for me it's like i feel like it's the
equivalent of a fighter you train you
train your train you train for nine to
12 weeks before your fight
and then that night you know
you just have fun you you've done it
you've done all the work you're supposed
to do i feel like the same way for a
tour or or just being prepared i play so
much when a gig comes up and they do
come up all the time hey travis i want
you to play the grammys with eminem or
we want you to play the grammys with
pitbull or
or with tom morello and chuck d
i'm just prepared because i'm playing
every day you know yeah
yeah it's very much uh
sort of an athlete's mindset you know
the training is
you know the training is the life right
and the the event the competition the
game whatever it's just a celebration of
all the work that went into getting you
there exactly and there's a lot of
parallels between drumming and
athleticism too because it is so
athletic yeah and for trump for you yeah
for drumming exactly that's the reason i
work out like i kind of work out like a
madman because i
number one i want to be able to go up
there and not get tired and i want to be
able to close my eyes and do
whatever my mind wants to do and i want
my body to be able to react and and and
be able to pull it off right so i i just
i feel like practicing all the time and
being in shape it's just it just goes
hand in hand with two hour sets with
blink because it's really
it's really an endurance competition out
there yeah
for blink you know right some of the
other gigs i get you know like
i just played with drum on on uh conan
and that's just fun but that comes to
just you know being versatile and
playing all types of music but when it
comes to playing a blink gig or a gig
with transplants or goldfinger or
whoever i'm playing with at the time
yeah
yeah you can't go out there and not
practice for four weeks and not train
and then go play a show and think you're
gonna have a great show yeah it's not
gonna happen you've done a really great
job of kind of sharing that experience
on instagram and snapchat with the
stories and i mean it's either like
you playing live just and you could see
like just how incredibly athletic it is
and it's just like oh my god you're just
going for it or it's you like with the
battle ropes working out
or cheap with the kids right yeah much
like and this is what your life is about
that's my life and and when you're
talking about kind of like your work
ethic and and how you still are so
ardent about um
you know
practicing the drums every day like what
an amazing
example for your kids right it's like
your kids are not growing up blue collar
right so do you do you worry about like
that kind of like that hunger like that
grit that you know is a part of your
success equation like how does that
translate into you know parenting kids
and and trying to make sure that they
have you know an enthusiasm for
something like you do yeah i mean
i do worry about that i came from
nothing and i was like
don't let me get off track here but i
was
at the time when when i when i graduated
from high school
and i had started like i got a tattoo on
my leg like one of my first tattoos and
my dad said if you ever get a tattoo
i'm gonna kick your ass and i'm gonna
kick you out of the house
so i got one and uh my sister tamara
actually ratted me out like i made her
upset or something she's like trav has a
tattoo
sure enough my dad's like hey pull down
your sock
i'm like why and he's like
i was told you have a tattoo and i was
like no no pal and i pull it down of
course the tattoo's there so
i didn't get whooped
and i didn't get kicked out of the house
so i figured out like whoa okay they
don't hurt
i love tattoos so my you know i just
loved the whole
ideas of tattoos so for me it was like
my dad was always telling me you have to
have a plan b you have to have a plan b
if you don't have a plan b
you're gonna be [ __ ] with you know all
these job stoppers and everything and i
was like
oh my gosh i'm going to listen to my
pops but i'm going to flip it on them
if i have tattoos i can't have a plan b
so it was perfect for me it was like
that's it and my goal you got to
remember was never to have millions of
dollars or never to be
the most famous person in the world it
was never any of that it was just it was
really simple
i want to play drums and somehow survive
like be able to feed yourself yeah i
don't care if i live on my friend's
couch whatever so the amount of courage
it takes to not have a plan b and just
to absolutely go for it and say i don't
care if i'm sleeping on a sleeping bag
on you know outdoors or on the floor or
if i'm eating rice cakes or whatever it
is as long as i get to do what i want to
do or i'm going to commit myself 110 to
that
like there's there's that's so powerful
and beautiful yeah i feel like if you
really want to do something unless
you're 110
sacrificed and ready to sacrifice
everything i didn't have no cool clothes
i didn't have a cool car i was poor
but i just wanted to play the drums not
for chicks not for any other reason but
that's what i loved you know so
back to my kids you know i hope
i hope they're seeing that now you know
they come home sometimes they're like
why are you practicing
i'm like
you know they're asking me if i have a
show coming up i said no there's no show
i'm just practicing you know they get it
like
it's like
you've got to put in work it's tons of
hard work so my daughter plays piano and
sings my son
sings and plays drums and raps he has
all sorts of stuff he loves doing
and i'm trying to install that same work
ethic in them and they've seen the grimy
side of being on punk rock tours
where you know we're playing in really
crappy venues and there's you know one
bathroom you share with the entire crowd
whatever and then they've been on
hip-hop tours with little wayne and rick
ross and
and nicki minaj and they've been on you
know blink tours that are massive and in
arenas all over the world so they've
seen everything they've been to the bet
awards with me when i'm playing with the
hip-hop artists they've been to the
grammys they've seen they've seen it all
and i'm hoping to just expose it to all
of them but at the end of the day if my
son comes home and says dad i want to be
a
whatever i don't know i want to work at
a library i'm going to support my son
110 if my daughter says
i want to be a veterinarian i'm going to
support her 110
i'm just exposing them to everything
while they're young and just seeing what
they love and
and they both have blood like music in
their blood it's so natural for them my
son is
such a phenomenal drummer and he doesn't
even practice it's insane
my little girl can sing her like butt
off and play piano it's just i just love
seeing it and i'm just trying to guide
them but i you know they're very aware
of where i came from and what i
sacrificed to get where i i am and what
an incredible education to be able to
bring them you know on the road and and
sort of ex have those kinds of
experiences and expose them to all
different kinds of people super
interesting but then balancing that
against any expectation of entitlement
you know that comes with that right yeah
it's got to be tough yeah it is it's uh
i mean parenting in general there's no
there's no guide to parenting you know
and and you know i'll meet like a
hundred you know five different parents
i know and everyone's so different it's
just you really it's just a
gamble you know trust your gut and guide
them and point them in the right
direction you know i just feel like
that's all you can do and lead by
example you know years ago when i when i
first got sober this uh
i was going through a divorce and and dj
am actually
who uh who passed away but before before
i'd make any big decisions he would be
like you need to sober up for four days
in order to make a decision you know so
i would be sober for those four days and
during that time we were both going to
this therapist because i was trying to
be sober and and aim was kind of helping
me but
this therapist said if you die today
would you be
the man you'd want your kids to remember
you by
and at that point
i wasn't i was very much like a dumpster
and a drug addict so i was like
oh my gosh
and when he said it to me it was like
ripped my heart out you know i couldn't
even like i was speechless i you know i
couldn't say anything and i think that's
resonated with me forever and it's just
lead by example and just know like
that's what they're seeing and and
everything i'm doing it's they're
absorbing like a sponge you know yeah
so i want to talk about the sobriety
stuff and and am and all of that but
maybe we'll get to it like let's i i
want to track back to something you said
a minute ago was just this idea of of
trusting your gut and and you know this
this instinct that you have that you
just wanted to be able to you know drum
and do what you love uh you know when
like when did you
when did you know like this is this is
it for me this is what it's going to be
was it like shortly around the time your
mom passed or
was there was there just a sense of like
this is it for me this is what it's
going to be there's no there's no plan b
all you know guns blazing forward
well right before she passed maybe like
those last two summers i was
skateboarding a lot
and the kids in the neighborhood they
basically i kind of started to zone in
and and it was kind of i woke up because
they in order to skate their half pipe a
lot of the older kids in the
neighborhood they'd be like you can't
come skate with us unless you if you
could play the drums learn learn master
of puppets from beginning to end by
metallica so i'd be like oh easy
whatever you know and that was my that
was my ticket to go hang out with all
the cool the kids that were like really
really incredible skateboarders in my
neighborhood
so i would learn all these and then
halfway through doing this and they'd
come over and they'd just come watch me
play and i remember playing one time and
going like
wow they're really tripping like they're
really impressed
that i can play the drums this is so
weird and then
they started learning how to play guitar
one of them was learning how to play
drums and i was like
man i've been doing this since i was
four like i'm way better at playing the
drums than i am skateboarding
and it was just
first i was in denial a little bit then
and then it just it just hit me and then
when mom my mom passed away and said
just play the drums just focus on what
you love you know don't stop don't let
anything stop you that was like
then the switch just flipped on it it
was just yeah the green light yeah
confirmation like
you you're realizing like
your drumming is allowing you to oddly
enough go skate the backyards and pools
you want to skate in the neighborhood
it was so good what other you know what
else could it do for you
like for you that was like awesome but
like imagine what else what other doors
it might open for you yeah it was a trip
and then that was it then in high school
i would take out i was relentless i
would there was a lot of papers at the
time everything from the recycler
to there was a paper in in our community
on the inland empire called mean street
and i would put ads out and i would i
was into so many different types of
music one might say like
a drummer looking for band influences uh
fugazi
pitchfork drive like jehu then the other
one would be like uh drummer looking for
band influences sound garden
allison chains
and
whatever and then another one drummer
looking for band descendants minor
threat and
you know what they're like all over the
place so that's that started because
you're still like that right so you were
never like i would have thought if i
didn't know better like oh you just you
know you're thinking about like cro-mags
minor threat black flag like i could see
you coming up from that kind of vein
yeah but being super focused on like
hardcore punk
but it was jazz it was
you know it was rap at the time it was
all different kinds of music right yeah
it was everything i figured like hey if
i'm gonna put my cards on the table let
me put them all out and see what what
you know
what what comes back so my dad would be
like
travis someone's on the phone for you
and it would be like every five minutes
and he would be so irritated he'd be
like what'd you do how did everyone get
this number and i mean it was everything
from those papers to local music shops i
just wanted to play with people right so
it wasn't about like getting a band
together it was about like i'm just
gonna play in 20 bands we'll eventually
get a band together but there's
something weird you know like if if you
were just a great guitar virtuoso and
you could just play guitar like no one's
business
but you didn't know how to play with
people it's a problem
and you can't teach somebody that it's
you know and there was no bands like
there was no now they have like these
cool rock star programs at schools and
stuff it's incredible but for me it was
like
i want to learn how to play with people
i want to learn how to like there's a
lot that goes into it it's like you
start learning how to like write your
drum parts in your head with whatever
songs you're creating with whatever
musicians you're playing with
so
i would have people you know from texas
coming to see me i would have
whole bands you know auditioning me for
whatever and i did that till i
just found cool local bands to play with
yeah super interesting i mean
that's sort of the the under appreciated
uh sort of skill of becoming a
successful musician right being able to
work with people i mean you know it's no
mystery most bands fail because no
people can't get along with each other
right yeah and i think 182 has had its
ups and downs with that like every other
band yeah i would imagine but
being able to have like a you know an
aptitude for communication and
understanding and compassion with the
people that you're playing with is
crucial right yeah it's part of it's
part of it i mean being in a band is
like
it you're having a relationship it's
almost like having a girlfriend and you
have to i believe there's like
relationship maintenance you have to do
with the people in the band you have to
obviously be
collaborative in in the writing process
and there is people i know that are
great musicians that i've come in
contact with over the years i've played
and uh and they can't hold on to gigs
because they are hard to work with or
they're
unnegotiable or just you know
hard-headed and it's just
people
dealing with people and being able to
work with people is a whole other skill
along with playing your instrument along
with you know what i mean everything
else it's part of so what is it if you
had to articulate like how you flow with
that like what is it about for you
like is it about collaboration is it
about being flexible like how do you
navigate
the you know the sort of personalities
that you come in contact with the people
that you collaborate with
it's just knowing how to deal with
people i don't even think it involves
music at that point it's just like how
do you do you have patience you know
what i mean i have kids i have the i
have the my son asked me the days like
how do you do it and i was like son i
i've had you know three kids i've raised
three of you guys i i know i have
patience dad knows how to i'm very
patient whereas like some people that
might not have kids
that are 39 or 40 years old that are
playing in a band maybe have zero
patients or have zero you know ways to
tolerate certain things whereas i'm like
okay this is how we work through this
you know and you know i guess i learned
i wasn't always like that i think i
learned it through businesses that i
started through
of course other others that led by
example that i looked up to
um
all that you know it's it's the
immediately when i got in the game and i
started touring i i was quiet and i
listened a lot
and learned right
so when does the first band kind of come
together for you that gets a little bit
of traction
in high school i was playing in a band
called poor mouth that would play like
every party and it was like it was kind
of awesome like we killed it but it was
very short-lived out there there wasn't
much going on like for me i didn't know
how i was ever going to get out of
fontana right so that's like inland
empire right yeah
and i kind of i kind of bounced around
from
fontana to riverside to corona i was
kind of everywhere there was a pivotal
moment where
you know i played in every local band
and
my dad was telling me he's like look
you're out of high school now you just
graduated
you
need to pay rent and you need to work 60
hours a week or you can't be here
and i you know of course i didn't want
to disappoint my dad
so i went and i kicked butt at the job i
was at and i finally got in at the
warehouse the shipping and receiving
center
and i got the job it was 60 hours a week
i couldn't believe it i was making more
than 425 an hour it was the most i
thought my life was made you know at
that time that was a lot of money for me
i think i was going to make i think i
was gonna start at 475 or five dollars
an hour right which was awesome and then
i just joined this band named feeble uh
with a lot of guys who ironically enough
grew up in fontana that moved to laguna
beach
and i called everyone one day i was like
i don't know if uh
i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
join the band anymore man i think i'm
just gonna stay here and maybe not play
drums as much right now because my dad
said i have to work 60 hours a week and
i need to pay rent and i don't want to
disappoint him
and
the singer of that band noel paris
said trav i think you're making a really
bad decision i think that you
are extremely talented and you have a
gift
and you'll look back on this and you'll
regret it and if you don't take this
opportunity
you you know
you you'll look back and you won't be
able to get this opportunity again but
you would be able to get another job
working 60 hours a week so please hear
me out and please listen to me
uh you're too good to waste your life
working at target
so i said screw it and i said dad i'm
i'm i listen to you and i'm leaving i'm
gonna go
sleep on my buddy's couch and i'm gonna
play in a band and be he got me a job
being a trash man in laguna
and i'm gonna play drums you know so he
he helped hook you up with a gig though
so it wasn't like he was pissed he was
like all right that's the choice he's
making and i'm going to get behind it
like what was his reaction who pops yeah
well he kind of gave me an ultimatum it
was either
you know
get with me
or you're on your own yeah he basically
said in not so many words stop playing
drums in the garage with your friends
get a 60-hour job you know uh a week job
or or get out of here you know nicely
you know because you need to be a man he
said you know
a man doesn't stay here and live off his
pops i love you but you've got to do
that and then
luckily noel just said man i i really i
really see something in you and i i
could really feel this and you you've
got to listen to me
and i just said screw it i'm going to do
it and um and i went out there and i i
just played in their band and and sure
enough noel was right like i i played in
their plan band i played in this this
local soccer band that would play at
hennessey's like this bar over there
and feeble we were all trash men we were
all laguna beach city workers yeah and
that's awesome and we would uh
day time we would be cleaning up trash
doing city work night time we'd be
playing a show every night of practicing
and then
sure enough that led to the aquabats
playing with us and seeing me
and the bass player chad larson calling
me and going
dude our drummer uh isn't going to be
able to play these shows or he quit the
band we need a drummer tomorrow we're
playing with fishbone at the glass house
wow and i was like duh i'm there right
you know in these like uh games it was
like the height so this was like late
80s mid 80s now this was like 90s this
is 95
or 96. so fishbone hit its peak like
around
late 80s right like they were they were
pretty yeah they were still there they
were still jamming i mean they were
selling out like the glass house right
000 3 000 people uh-huh so that's a big
step up oh huge i mean we went from you
know i was playing local bars some of
them twice the size of this with feeble
and we just you know we were such a good
band but we we weren't connected in the
music industry we were a really great
band but uh we weren't playing big
venues and then the aquabats had hit me
up
and i played that show
and they were just like you're our
drummer man and i didn't know they
dressed up or anything i just showed up
there with some drumsticks i had heard
the album the night before
and then it was the hardest thing for me
but i had to
i had to tell you know because aquabats
had a tour i was touring now my dream
was coming true
and i had to go and tell my one of my
best friends like a brother to me noel
and the rest of the guys in feeble who
ultimately
directed me and guided me to be out
there and follow my dreams that i'm now
leaving their band because i got an
opportunity to tour with the aquabats
that's a tough conversation it was
terrible it was terrible
um what did noel say i mean i think he
was upset and i think i think everyone
was upset
i think
i think all of them would have
probably done what i did because they
they were they wanted the dream so bad
just like i did ironically like i said
they were from fontana there's not no
one comes out of fontana no one's doing
anything like i think they were i think
they were on one hand very proud of me
and the other hand like oh man you can't
believe this are those guys still
playing music yeah i still talk to him
oh that's good yeah yeah we're still
friends no i mean when i wrote my book
noel actually contributed to my book
and uh and i called him many of times
and just thanked him right you know
that's cool so
you're so suddenly i mean how what is
the time period from getting the getting
the gig as a trash man in laguna
to getting the tour it was probably
about a year and a half yeah so you you
so you paid your dues during that year
right oh yeah you were telling me the
other day about like how you would uh
the hari krishnas would give you food
yeah uh-huh yeah i would just skate you
know i didn't have a car
you know which goes back to what we were
talking about earlier you sacrifice
everything i had no car all i had was a
skateboard to my name but there was
there was something they were all in man
yeah you know there were some days i
didn't have much money and harry
krishnas would give us half a chips and
they would have you know food like a
little buffet for whoever i don't i
don't know what it was for it was
probably just for them but we made
friends with like the guys from shelter
and a couple other people there so we
would eat it was awesome yeah so you go
on tour with uh aquabats and then you
guys get signed and do an album right
yeah we got signed to
actually paul to let there was a lot of
offers on the table from different
people
and paul tollett who who owns golden
voice
signed the aquabats basically created a
record label to sign the aquabats
wow it was awesome um and bill fold at
the time was my manager
who
who at the time where i grew up in
riverside in fontana he had a place
called the barn
which had the best shows ever like ev
all the great bands would go through
there you know your dream if you came
from where i came from was to play the
barn or spankies or any of those punk
rock clubs out there so yeah we we
rode and and recorded an album it came
out on golden voice paul toulette
and and we were off we were off running
man we had like songs on k rock we
filmed music videos
it was a trip right so you've already
like exceeded your like wildest
imagination for where you thought you
would go right mm-hmm and then and then
what happens you guys you guys end up
being uh opening for blink 182 is that
how it goes down is that the next yeah i
tour with them for maybe two years
recorded two albums with them and
we are on snow core with blink 182
which was like primus the alcoholics
um
blink
aquabats who else is on there
um i feel like someone else popped on
and off that tour but we did that tour
with them and at the end of that tour
aquabats were a great support act for
blink meaning we'd play rep before blink
every night
and
kind of oddly enough man the same thing
happens i'm in the aquabats and
blinks drummer leaves they have a
falling out like 40 minutes before their
show
and
aquabats are are about to play and
they're like dude
our drummer just left i think you quit
can you learn
20 songs in like 40 minutes and i was
like uh sure you know 20 songs in 40
minutes yeah and luckily like some
nights
you it just happens naturally too you go
out you know you go out and you watch
the bands before you or after you
just to support and kind of check it out
so i'd kind of seen some of this stuff
but i wasn't listening to it with the
ear that oh i'm gonna have to play this
i was just like oh this is cool whatever
they were fun to watch they were really
funny and mark and tom really loud and
kind of ignorant and just you know uh
just you know like a fun fun fun band
and
that day we just got in the dressing
room i said tom just play me all the
songs on guitar i just need to see how
you're picking and what the rhythms are
and
40 minutes later hopped on stage played
our first show that's crazy that's
insane so it wasn't about mimicking
every single drum stroke so that you
could be you know
exactly the same as the drummer who
preceded you but it was about finding
your own way to play these songs yeah
uh-huh yeah and then being able to tap
into that in just 45 minutes for 20 i
mean that's that goes back to like the
past life thing like you being able to
learn music you know sheet music at age
four or five like the fact that you
could
channel that like so intuitively is
pretty amazing yeah it was awesome man
it was and me for me i was having so
much fun i was like
playing two sets a night
so i did it for like the next four or
five shows uh-huh
and after the first one they said we
want you to be our drummer
and i said well
i think you have a drummer he just left
though
you know it's kind of like a girl you
meet a girl and she's like nuts about
you like oh my gosh and you're like you
have a boyfriend like hit me when you
don't have a boyfriend it was kind of
that same scenario i told him i was like
well if things don't work out with your
drummer he doesn't come back obviously
i'd love to play with you
and they were you know we've never
sounded better we love this and
we got home from tour the shows were
over and and they said you know what
we're going to call you in a week and
let you know what's up
call me in a week they say
you got a show tomorrow night 6 pm be
there
and it was just it was just green light
yeah it was like that was it
and then you gotta you have to go back
to the aquabats and have that same
conversation same thing yes we were we
were actually doing what's called grad
night at disneyland where they would
have i think no doubt did it the year
before and scott was so popular then you
know was that was like the no doubt
phenomenon spilling over into fontana it
was kind of happening a little bit
before you right or around the same time
because it was you know they're orange
county so not too far away yeah scott
punk
and punk rock was just
everywhere you know so we would play
with no doubt you know aquabats would
open for them
we did grad night the year after them so
those were my last shows and i remember
i had to tell them same thing like hey
yeah it was just so weird man every time
i felt guilty i don't know i don't know
if i should have felt guilty but i did
and uh
and you just like i said the the people
you play with they become your brothers
it was just it became like a family and
and it was hard i remember
you know
us bawling the last day i told them you
know it's i'm gonna go play with blank
and
they just couldn't believe it
you know yeah and for me it was like
man am i
am i a jerk you know what i mean like
you're a climber yeah am i a climber am
i like
what am i what am i supposed to do and i
and i just thought you know aquabats had
like nine people in the band
we were in like a 10 passenger van
sometimes there was 13 people in a 10
passenger van
just
it was just it was it was rough and and
uh
and it just it just seemed like
the right thing to do yeah i just
trusted my god how are those guys doing
now what are they doing great we're
still great friends
and
christian
contributed to my my book can i say it
was really cool christian contributed to
it and so did
nol
and the guys from feeble for it so
having both of them i told them meant so
much to me and and i let them tell their
story you know they they were honest
like right you know christian says i was
pissed i couldn't believe it like
and um
and even i just i learned stuff about
myself just from their interviews in my
book which was cool yeah it's almost
like it's out there because i didn't do
that you know i i didn't interview
people for my book i had gavin edwards
who i co-wrote the book with he would do
these interviews and he would say we're
keeping everything in there
and i'd be like oh my gosh
perspective on you and i'd be like your
decisions so some people might not be
you know i remember like christian said
like he kind of talked bad about blink
and i was like should i put that in
there that's kind of
i don't know he's like everything stays
in there you've got to be brutally
honest and you know christian even said
like you know i felt like
travis was so good when he was in our
band he he was like the michael jordan
of drumming and sometimes he would
listen to me and he would play songs
faster than i wanted him to play him but
i never heard those things when i was in
the band so it was like i really
listened when i read it in my book and i
was like wow i never realized i was
being like that or i never you know what
i mean or i never realized you viewed me
like that or whatever compelling though
that makes for a compelling memoir
because you're getting you're getting
the truth yeah i mean and that's what
you really want out of a mem too many
memoirs are glossy whitewashed you know
sort of best of versions of somebody's
life you know and it's not it's not
honest so and i was so happy i did that
there was a there's a couple things you
know i was brutally honest about a lot
and the day after it came out the day it
came out it was uh
i remember being really emotional
because i was just going like oh my gosh
everything i shared
i'm almost having to relive again
because i'm doing press for the book
and i found out i wasn't prepared for it
just to talk about certain things i was
still very emotional about it
so it was like oh it was draining man i
was so it was just crazy but then a
couple days after the book came out i'm
like i'm so glad i was honest yeah
because i can't go back and go
i didn't say this and i wanted to in my
book it's like i pretty much said it all
besides things that i wasn't legally not
allowed to say yeah it's cathartic you
know but it's a very vulnerable feeling
like i experienced my version of that uh
you know when my book came out and
knowing that i'd been honest about stuff
that i wasn't proud of you know yeah
and and only being able to write that
by sort of pretending or imagining that
i was writing in a journal no one was
ever going to read and then realizing
like oh man this is like out there yeah
and
you know i don't have you know i have
like one one thousandth the profile that
you have so to know that like mainstream
america like all knows that all this
stuff about your life is it
is a is an inexplicably vulnerable
feeling right yeah imagine i can't
imagine what that must have been like
yeah it was a trip but it's like but
you're clear right you're clear yeah you
know what i mean i really felt a huge
weight lifted off my shoulders
and just
i can put i can move on now right you
know
so blank blows up
and i would imagine that kind of changes
the
the tenor of your life right yeah i mean
that just was it must have been an
insane time i came home and i told my
pops i was just filling in for blink and
i was like dad i made like i have three
thousand dollars right now and he's like
you better hold on to it cause you're
never gonna get it again and i was like
thanks dad
i was like i was like thanks a lot he's
like i'm serious tribe you don't know
when you're gonna make it again
and then that was before i'd you know
they called me the week later
and then
i started going on tour and i remember
my pops like
you know we we came from lower middle
class you know family and he didn't you
know he didn't have a running car he had
like this old cadillac in the back of
his backyard that that i would like hose
off for him and wash but it didn't run
so my first paycheck i came and i bought
him a cadillac and i just it was just a
trip you know i could like
i went i the first things i did was
helped out my dad and my sisters made
sure they were cool
and then how many sisters yeah two two
yeah what are they doing now
um one works at my print shop and the
other one works at my clothing company
oh cool famous yeah yeah nice man yeah
that's cool taking care of your family
but i would imagine like
suddenly you know it's bling city right
yeah it's uh
it's going because even blink at the
time we were still we were playing small
clubs we were playing clubs around
across america and europe
our first uh
tour in europe was in a van it was still
very much it was kind of picking up
right we're a little bit bigger than
aquabats you know
and
and then we recorded
our album the first album i recorded
with them was called enema of the state
and we just blew up blew up it was just
insane did you see that like when you
made the decision to to move over to
blank like did you see that potential on
the horizon like did you have the idea
like this this band's gonna go further
and bigger and broader yeah well because
at the time aquabats they still are
they're very much
uh i guess focused on children
and
a lot of good good qualities about them
no cussing uh they're all mormon so it
all fits into what what they can and
can't do
but their end goal what really what
really you know cried out to me was
their end goal was to have a television
show have a cartoon and my end goal was
to play in a rock band
yeah so i didn't i you know
being in the aquabats if i just put it
down on paper it'd been like okay i'm
gonna
play drums in a band that i love like
interesting music really cool new wave
ska
great guys but at the end of the day
christian really wanted it to be a tv
show
and for me i was like i don't know if i
want to be an actor or whatever i was
like i really just want to play the
drums and
play fast and fun and just you know and
it was a three piece so it was just
it was very minimal and and fun and and
i knew who blink was you know i had
listened to some of their albums and it
just it just made a lot of sense
so enema of the state blows up and at
this time like mtv's still pretty
relevant right like yeah so you're and
you're all over that we're on trl we're
like number one on the countdowns where
like
there's people sleeping outside of my
gate and my house wow uh in corona where
i had just moved and i had no idea i was
i i needed to move out just because i
there was no privacy there there was
people trying to break in my house
there was like stalkers
there was girls trying to handcuff
themselves to me after shows it was
there was a lot of strange things going
on that i was just like
are you serious like how did you manage
that like did you manage it well or were
you just in for the ride or like how did
that go down for you i was in for the
ride but i was in a little bit of
disbelief because we didn't really you
know we were just we were a pop punk
band right you know it was goofy yeah
who loved the descendants and
and all and black flag and whatever all
these bad religion all these bands we
just grew up on and then all of a sudden
you know
a a network like mtv gets behind you and
is just saying you have the number one
video in the world
um people from our genre music weren't
ready for that we didn't know what to do
we didn't even know what that was we
were like
it was insane but yeah i mean we figured
it out you know obviously with with
the success shows got bigger we were
playing arenas now
you know making
million dollar videos at the time a
record label at the time
was like you're at the point of your
career where you need to make a million
dollar video can you believe that
yeah i know oh my gosh man it was just
did they ever do that anymore no yeah no
i mean they figured it out like you do
not need a million dollars for a video
um but you know we had like the guy
samuel bayer who did like smells like
teen spirit guy yeah
and we're
traveling around in private jets it's
just right playing two or three shows a
day sometimes
it was it was insane and and are you
happy like are you like i'm living the
dream this is awesome or how's this
landing for you oh yeah it was just more
of like a i was like foggy i didn't i
couldn't believe it it was just i'm just
i'm just along for the ride i'm just
cruising you know rolling with the
punches like whatever whatever they
spring on me i'm going okay i'm down
whatever you know we want you to play on
top of the whatever empire state
building okay we then you're going over
to trl and then you're gonna go play
uh madison square garden and i'm like i
don't even know what madison square
garden is you're gonna play this show
called saturday night live i don't know
what saturday night live is it was i had
no i had no clue i always say one of the
funniest things we played saturday night
live i didn't know
how
insanely special
it is
to play saturday night live i had no
clue it was just another tv show i know
that though i just didn't grow up like
watching you at the time like 25 or
something yeah yeah probably but i
didn't grow up watching tv i grew up
skateboarding watching skate videos
listening to punk rock and you know
trying to mimic mike d from the beastie
boys
i was not i was not watching late night
television i just didn't even
i knew who jay leno was because my dad
was such a big car guy like love cars
but yeah it was a trip wow so touring
what was the most like surreal thing
that happened during that era
um
i'm just a massive taurus just going to
i mean you take you take a band that was
playing two to three thousand seaters
and after enema of the state we had this
wrote this incredible album and we're
out playing
you know to 10 to 30 000 people a night
you know all summer long and it was just
the only time it stopped is when we
begged for it to stop just don't book
shows for a month or two or we were so
over i mean i don't i don't call it
overworked because we get to do what we
love but there comes a point and i
always say this
there comes a point when
you're on the road your management's
back home and they just keep booking
shows
and there is
there is a such thing as a cash register
yeah there is a such thing as sanity you
know and uh and ultimately like that led
to me doing a lot of drugs
was just no one
saying hey is everything cool out there
like do you guys need to come up for air
we were touring like nine months ten
months out of the year yeah it was
insane so
sometimes we'd get home and mark tom and
i would get on the phone they're like
who's gonna say they're sick
i'd be like i'm sick and he's like yeah
man i don't think we could do like the
first week of this tour we're gonna have
to postpone the first week of this story
crazy because you guys are like 25
you're like your veins are coursing with
testosterone like if you guys can't
manage it like nobody can yeah i think
it was just it's just insane like at the
time you're away from your families you
just there comes this cold time
eight months into touring where you
haven't been home you haven't seen your
family and you haven't had a break where
you're just like
i need a minute yeah just real quick
give me a minute give me one day off
give me two days off and we're cool you
know
um but yeah i i think you know it was uh
it was just insane so it was awesome so
uh so the drugs start creeping in a
little bit like what are you doing like
smoking a little pot like are you do the
painkillers come in or is that only
after like the injury well for me um
i started smoking cigarettes for
whatever reason while i was out there
and and uh
and i didn't like to fly when i was 19
and i was in feeble and i was a trash
man
i got drunk for the first time and i
told my manager
i'm gonna die in a plane crash
and he was like what are you talking
about you've never even had enough money
to fly in your life and i was like
you're right i haven't i've never i've
only flown once in my life and it was
the scariest thing in the world but
i cried to him after being like
having like too much alcohol for the
first time and said i'm gonna die in a
plane crash it was the weirdest thing so
it was a trip yeah and i didn't know
note to self i did not know that until
he did his interview for my book and he
reminds me that i said that and i was
like oh my gosh i did say that that's
that's so scary to me
so fast forward to blink we're flying
four three times a day sometimes we're
knocking out a show in the morning a
today show whatever a morning show from
the news uh an early festival time a
slot at one festival and then at night
playing our own show
so we're flying all the time and that's
when so the anxiety is there is some
anxiety rationing up oh yeah
i think tom was honestly i think tom was
the first one he was like here's a norco
like these will
this will like calm you down if you get
stressed or whatever on flights and i'd
always be white knuckling and they'd be
like dude it's fine it's just the
landing gear going up and they would
always tease me but flying i think i
think the one time i flew at a young age
i saw my mom and she was bawling the
entire time on the flight because she
was so scared
and i think that maybe had something to
do with how i felt about flying
so i'd be white knuckling every time
we'd fly and we'd be on these small
planes
sometimes it'd be a private jet
sometimes we'd fly commercial we just
never knew it was just in europe the
planes were old even it was just it was
something i really learned to hate i
just did not like flying anything i
could do
um
to forget i was on an airplane so it led
to me taking handfuls of of norcos and
vicodin and valium
which later led to like oxycontin right
um
tons of of weed
and then sherm pcp
weed laced with pcp uh
it was just anything anything to
to not realize i was on a plane again
right it's interesting that it all
germinates from that right like that
fear and and again like i can't get i
can't get past like this
it's it really does feel like this weird
past life thing like this knowing that
you had like you're supposed to avoid
airplanes you know yeah like just this
intuition that you had about it and
every time you got on a plane knowing
that that was across purposes with what
your inner self was telling you yeah i
mean everyone
i mean if am was still here he would say
travis was a mess on airplanes you know
mark and tom
you know
the worst flyer ever you know they would
just point at me and laugh because i
just i mean it wouldn't be screaming but
you could just look at my face i'd stay
up the whole time just waiting you know
well can we talk about the the plane
crash yeah of course you're okay with
that i mean
you know it's well documented and
everything like that but you know it's
quite
you know it was quite the tragic
encounter i just i can't imagine you
know what that must have been like
trying to you know overcome that but
maybe you know walk us through exactly
what happened
um so
dj am and i there was a point where
the
mark and tom and i it was it was lots of
touring like i had said i think it had
you know taken its toll on everybody and
blink
tom you know just basically tom one day
just said i'm done
he couldn't do it no more it was like
you know there was miscommunication with
management
and
some of us wanted to tour all the time
and uh he wanted to stay home a lot it
was just it was a mess so blink breaks
up
about four months later transplants my
other band
breaks up
and i'm like
what am i gonna do
i'm so used to being a busybody i'm used
to doing everything
everywhere
so i meet dj am and
he's a great dj that plays everything
everything he plays things people would
wouldn't dare have the balls to play in
a club and he and he just makes it
iller than anyone could ever imagine you
know so we we connect
and i tell him like yo i have this idea
or it's drummer dj
i don't know and you know i'm not doing
anything right now my my bands are on
time off right now we should jam and
he's like i'd love to
we start jamming the first time we jam
we jammed for like 10 hours
and it was just he was like a guitar
player throwing every genre of music at
me the beatles throwing
uh whatever you know ghetto boys
throwing
uh you know daft punk
everything you know it was magic i mean
he was so innovative and what he was
doing way ahead of the curve yeah way
ahead of his time
so long story short we developed this
routine that was like to me was really
innovative no one was doing it was
mind-blowing man we were on to something
we were playing like k-rock weenie
roasts we were playing all the venues
and gigs my bands were playing back in
the day uh a week before our plane crash
we were we're the house band for mtv
music awards you know it was
ill it was the best time ever
um
so we had gigs
i was gigging just as much as with am as
i was bling big shows too it was just
him and i it was crazy
so it was it was one of those days where
i i
we had a show is for like t-mobile and
they would pay us big money to go and
play these shows and it was in south
carolina and
remember before we left i was like i
don't really
need to go it's summer
and and my my my baby's mama
shayna at the time
we weren't together but she was like
don't go then like if you don't have to
go you don't need the money it's like
why are you doing it and i was like i'm
doing it because i love playing with
adam and i think adam was going through
the same thing like
we don't have to go but it was just one
of those things that's booked let's
honor what we committed to so we flew
out to south carolina wasn't uh wasn't
shanna gonna come with you yeah shayna
was gonna come my kids were bawling man
it was like it was the weirdest thing my
kids were bawling my little girl alabama
was saying
she's freaking the whole time she's
never done this she's crying saying the
roof's gonna come off
i'm like what are you talking about bama
and she's a baby at the time and she's
just
the kids are crying not normal like
weird you know
and yeah like like i said my gut this is
one of the big examples of where i was
like my gut told me not to go
so i end up going and she was gonna go
with us but she's like nah i shouldn't
go just in case god forbid something was
to happen we'd both be in that plane
so we go and uh the flight out there is
cool i take
my assistant little chris
and uh
and our we just had a big homie named
che who was like our good friend
and he was like he was playing college
football
i basically chris and i were like dude
instead of hiring security for now we
should just take che with us che is
going to be security for now on because
it's it's good having friends on tour
with you too and chase big and you know
intimidating
shay's never been on a private plane uh
you know we go out there on a g4
everything's cool we play our show
and then after the show
um
we had a flight booked for tomorrow
everything was everything was set up but
uh am's like oh i want to get back
tonight like
you know what are we gonna do in south
carolina you know and then chris had
just had his son sebastian who's my
godson
he's like yeah man we should just go
home trav um
and i was like well we have a flight
book tomorrow don't trip let's just
chill here you guys
but it's like majority rules anywhere we
go if i get out voted i'm i'm rolling
with the punches you know and everyone
was like skills yeah
so i took one for the team i said okay
whatever man let's book the flight
whatever
so booking flights like this usually
like the the flight out there it's like
i speak to a manager
and i say who's the pilot
what's the plane what's the history is
everything cool oh wow so you're getting
into it oh i'm really i'm terrified of
flying
so
and ironically enough the the flight out
there was
cake piece of cake man we knew the pilot
was he was super cool he knew i was a
little bit weird about flying
you know
um great flight though on the way back
you got to think man we just got off
stage it's
9 30 10 o'clock
and we make the phone call get us a
plane
so the plane is booked
in an hour's time
no there's no one
doubting the eyes or crossing the t's
it's like yo you guys want a plane i'm
gonna do everything i can do to get this
plane there
so the plane gets there and so implying
that like shortcuts were made on the
checklist or i know my checklist wasn't
done you know because gus who was our
tour manager for blink you know
usually there was like a you know
there's a little checklist that goes and
i know that checklist wasn't going to
happen it was an hour's time and lv is
like dude it's not going to be the
greatest plane but i'll get it
once again rolling with the punches you
know whatever for the team so we get
there we pull up to the airport and it's
like private airport and there's all
these jets and then there's this [ __ ]
leer over all by itself and i was like
oh cold as ice tell me that is not our
plane
and sure enough the driver drives up to
that plane and i'm just looking at it
no
you know
bad bad feeling man bad feeling
my gut's saying no it to the point where
i actually called my dad
who at the time now i say i love you
every time i speak to him he's like
75 but growing up he's a vietnam vet
he's tough and tough tough dad you know
and uh i know he loved me but we
wouldn't say i love you or be gushy you
know it was like more tough love i'm not
a hugger yeah
for for him and i so i call him and i'm
like i'm bawling at this point and i say
dad like i have a really bad feeling but
you were crying before you even got on
yeah
i'm crying my dad's like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you trav why are you
crying and i said dad i don't know i
have a horrible feeling
if something happens pal
just
do whatever you can to make sure the
kids are cool
because i have a horrible feeling and
he's like well you're gonna be fine you
know and i take a picture of the plane i
send it to like
i think i sent it to
my pops i sent it to my boy rob
that's in the transplants with me
weird enough chris does the same thing i
don't know that he does this but he
sends a a picture of him in front of the
plane to his wife
um
we get in the flight
there's like a really young pilot and it
kind of like eased off some of the
pressure because she was really young
and i was like wow you look really young
i was like you fly the plane she's like
yeah i'm i'm like getting my hours up or
whatever you know she's basically you
know
she's with like an og captain that's you
know flying with her you know teaching
her
so we get in there and she's basically
like okay well there's no room for a
stewardess in this plane so i'll be up
in the cockpit if you guys need anything
you know just come knock on the door
whatever so we get in the flight and i'm
[ __ ] baked man i've smoked so much
weed and i've taken so many pills it's
my normal concoction to get on the
flight you know especially this one i'm
going heavy you know um
we get on everyone's like
there's actually a video man i have the
video of it am back in the day there was
these flip cams i don't know if you
remember
they were like the coolest thing before
every phone had one and he's on the
fight and he's like what do you know
about a
uh drummer a dj and a pj like you know
like kind of like kind of flexing a
little bit we're on a private jet
whatever having trying to have fun and
chris is like you know what's up chris
whatever we're just goofing off like you
know thinking we're just living in the
lap of luxury on a private flight home
everyone else is i'm scared
to death already you know
so
chris falls asleep chad falls asleep
we're still on the runway and i'm like
wide awake man i'm just sitting there
adam's sleeping
we go up and down the runway we're going
the wrong way
and they turn around all the way on the
runway yeah like so right out there like
sorry yeah we're sorry we went down the
wrong runway and i was like oh my gosh
man what the hell you know
and then uh
and then i'm kind of like dozing off and
then finally you know you feel like the
engines start up again
and we go to take off and our uh
our
our landing gear like the tire basically
our tires explode
it sounds like gunshots you know
not very many people will know what it
sounds like when your tires explode on
your plane so it sounded like someone's
shooting at the plane multiple tires
yeah
like if one went out yeah
it sounded like someone was you know
like throwing rounds you know so i hear
like these these loud bangs
and then the plane
is like skidding on the runway so we
have no tires so now it's landing gear
against the runway
and then smoke just starts filling the
cabin
and
fire immediately because the friction
from the landing gear on the wrong way
and then we go up in the air
and then ah you have to lift off yeah
and then we we lift off so we're hearing
from the captain from the cockpit at all
no i'm just screaming because i feel
like i know something's wrong once the
bang bang happened the plane kind of got
out of control then we were up in the
air so i'm screaming man and it's just
black in the in in the plane and smoke
everywhere
and then uh the plane is basically going
up
high and then it's dipping down and then
going up
and then dipping down and uh
and then it started it started getting
lower and hitting the the cement
going up and down
yeah bouncing off the cement and i'm
screaming man i'm screaming like but
obviously they have their hands full in
the cockpit who knows what's going on
and then we go
and by this time there's fire everywhere
and i'm looking at fire no longer smoke
it's fire and um
we swoop up i think we swoop up and down
like five or six times and then the last
time we go really high in the air it
almost felt like we were almost like
going vertical and then all of a sudden
the plane swoops down and we hit an
embankment
and we stop
and i'm somehow alive you know every
time i'm just bracing myself because i'm
looking out the window i'm wide awake
i'm numb i'm on so many painkillers and
whatever else so i'm seeing a swoop down
so i can kind of like brace myself every
time we hit
finally we hit and
i'm on fire
you know there's literally i'm on fire
yeah like my hands are on fire um i'm
trying to move forward to see if i can
get to chris or che there's four of you
in the cabin yeah um
and then my my whole everything catches
fire my shirt catches fire
and then i turn to my left
and am's knocked out and i grab him and
i shake him
he wakes up
i can't get to chris or che it's just a
wall of fire i can't see anything
so i open
i open the emergency exit which i always
i forgot to say but i always sit next to
an emergency exit in any plane
i sit i open the kick open the emergency
exit i jump out and i land in the jet
so i land in in the jet which if anyone
knows about planes like behind the like
in the jet stream behind the engine yeah
which is filled with fuel right so my
whole body catches fire i jump into a
basically a pool of jet fuel
um
my whole body catches fire am
jumps out over the jet he's not on fire
and he's basically on the phone i'm
running and he's screaming he's on the
phone with our manager
going our plane crashed he's like crying
screaming he's like trap's on fire
so i'm just running and at this time the
embankment was right next to a freeway
so i have cars that are watching me run
on fire and i'm just stripping off my
clothes
my gut tells me to strip off my clothes
i don't know what else to do we're in
the middle of the road this at this
point cars are coming in both directions
yeah the cars are like facing us and
there's no one on our side because
everyone sees the plane there and um
and i don't realize my skin is soaked in
jet fuel so it doesn't matter what i
take off so i get to the point where i'm
butt naked and i'm just
running but my whole body's on fire and
then i just hear one guy man like i
don't even i don't even know where he
was i know he's off to the left of me
that just says
like what you learned in elementary
school like stop drop and roll draw and
roll yeah and sure enough yelling from a
car yeah
yelling from a car
and i i just lay down and i start
rolling and then adam comes out dj am
and he he gets his shirt and he starts
patting me out and that's how he um got
burnt a little bit he got a little burnt
on his arm
and on his neck but basically
after a couple minutes he pats me out
and then
as he pats me out the plane explodes
and you are the you're the only two guys
who made it out yeah
yeah we're the only two guys um i mean
later we found out we found out chris
and che my assistant in my security they
weren't wearing their seat belts so they
they died immediately of head trauma
probably the first couple times the
plane did the the crazy you know up and
down um
found out unfortunately the
the pilots um
were burnt
um
and uh
and we were the only two survivors and
so intense man yeah it was insane
i mean you two guys like you just i mean
the fact that you even made it out it's
just it's unbelievable oh yeah i mean
knowing i mean watching the plane blew
up
like seconds after maybe
50 60 seconds afterwards that's just and
it's like that's like out of a movie
like that doesn't happen no
yeah i mean i think it had everything to
do with maybe where i was sitting
i was always so
crazy i'd sit next to the mirror at the
emergency exit i always had my seatbelt
on
um
studying that card yeah instructions
yeah i was just always so freaked out
you know i wouldn't sleep until takeoff
i would listen to every little noise but
yeah and then uh
long story short i spent the next
four months
in a burn center i had 28 surgeries
28 so second and third degree burns all
down your legs right yeah all my feet my
legs all the way up to my waist um
yeah just surgery after surgery skin
grafts and you know what you came close
to losing your foot or your leg at one
hand my right foot was almost amputated
so yeah it was uh there was that you
know there was four months of the burn
center and then there was probably
another
i think we played our first show
seven months after
the plane crash
and i couldn't have done it any any
sooner i didn't even once i got home
i was so
i was just
it was it was insane the medicine they
had me on in the hospital yeah that must
have just amped up
all of that like big time and just just
medicating like the trauma of what you
had experienced right and the survivor
guilt yeah i had tons of survival guilt
i had um
suicidal tendencies i was crazy um and
then i was on so many drugs i didn't
even realize maybe a month into being in
the hospital i said where's chris and
where's jay
i want to go in their rooms i just
figured they were in there with me yeah
you're just checked out it was it was
insane and then when i got home
um fast forward you know four months
after the burn center i go home and i'm
on like
19 different drugs
and they say you're going to be on these
the rest of your life you need this
bipolar medicine you need this
and it was even scarier man i would like
bipolar yeah like ptsd or like what is
yeah for ptsd because i was you know i
was 5150 in the hospital they were
it was uh there was some really dark
times there but um and even when i got
home i would walk down the street it
took me a month to even go outside and
then i walked down the street and i saw
a plane in the air and i would run and
hide in a bush i was like
yeah it was it was i was a crazy person
i didn't even i was scared you know but
adam being kind of like a you know
well-known long-time sober dude like you
know was he
where is he at this moment
so is he is he trying to is he trying to
like you know shock you out of this
condition that you're in is he trying to
help you out at all well adam goes and
we had therapists that we had spoke to
leading up before the plane crash just
to try to get me sober and to keep him
sober
and after the plane crash he started
seeing someone different
and i mean he would come and visit me
once i got normal about a month after i
got home i wouldn't call it normal
but i was a little better i wasn't you
know as strange and
and uh you know even even when i got
home there was a week
probably a week of
threatening to commit suicide and trying
to get my gun and just really
i don't know just in a really dark place
and then maybe a month later adam and i
you know started kind of meeting up and
he's like
let's just talk man i want to know what
you remember and what i remember and we
would just share stories and
he would tell me you know i finally at
one point
which is good to note i just i said you
know what man i
i had heard my uncle talking about me
and i heard one of my best friends going
like
dude travis isn't the same
he's like slow and he's we know i heard
people talking about me and to me it was
like these medicines are [ __ ] me up
like i shouldn't be on them i feel weird
on them you know
and my doctor was like you're probably
going to need them for the rest of your
life and one day i just grabbed them and
i threw them in the trash i flushed them
down the toilet and i had like a week of
anxiety some of the worst anxiety i've
ever had just weaning myself off of them
and i just smoked weed i smoked a little
bit of wheat every day to go to sleep
you know because i wasn't when i got
home i don't think i slept for like 72
hours straight i was just having
flashbacks and somehow the medication
from the hospital versus the medication
you know i was on morphine for five
months straight in the hospital i got
home and the medicine wasn't the same i
was losing my mind you know i was like i
couldn't sleep i was having flashbacks i
was like
oh i swear like i was just supposed to
die it was like final destination
someone was gonna come out of the sky
and kill me
and then uh
i got to an okay place and am and i
started talking and he said trav we need
to go to this spot where they retrain
your brain
we've got to do this i said i'll go with
you
so we do this therapy
and i just told am i saying man for me
65 of my body was burnt man i'm not
gonna forget what happened i'm not gonna
forget that was the idea trying to make
it so that you couldn't remember it yeah
and that's what this place supposedly
sold us on you know and i was like i'm
gonna look down every day and know 65
percent of my body was burnt in a plane
crash and i lost my two best friends and
it's not
you're not gonna there's no way you can
convince me that didn't happen but i'll
go so we went to all these therapy
classes together
um
but then on the side he was seeing a new
therapist just for ptsd and i was seeing
the same one that i was in the hospital
with that talked me out of
you know there was a point where in the
hospital i said i called one of my
buddies and i said man i'll transfer a
million dollars to you if you just smoke
me i'm i'm done just off you yeah uh i
didn't know yeah that's how dark it is
yeah i didn't get to see my kids i
didn't even like i didn't even
i it sounds weird to say but i didn't
even i couldn't see them i wasn't no one
could come in my room because i was so
prone to infection with all these open
sores i just was not in my right mind
so he starts seeing a therapist that
says
you were in a plane crash it's okay to
take xanax
to a guy who has
like i don't know i think 13 years ago
he had a lot of time at that time yeah
he was he was i mean he was the guy
getting me sober you know so she says
it's okay
you know you were you went through this
horrible experience a terrific
experience
take whatever you need to take and he
starts taking his xanax
because he's flying
yeah
so he's taking that and i can kind of
tell there's a difference in him
but uh just activate the demon you know
yeah and at this time i'm home i'm with
my kids in a matter of
two weeks i throw away all their
medication
my kids are my
dude they're my strength they're my
support everything i have
like you know i have the best support
team ever they're they're there watching
me recover and i'm like i'm finally in a
good head space i'm talking to my ptsd
person every every day everything was
getting much better
and we had lunch one day and he's just
like man i don't uh you know you have
the kids and you have like
you know these things to live for and
lead by example i don't have anybody
and you know at that point i was just
like well
i mean we we looked online there was no
like uh like playing plane crash
survivor
support groups really there was like hey
if you've lost someone in a plane crash
come here this is a support group
but we were kind of in a unique
situation where we didn't have a lot of
survivors to talk to so i said man we
have each other you know
whatever you need any time of day
just like you were there for me before
the accident whatever
i'm here you know so we would talk all
the time and just you know keep each
other straight because
we had a
we had something very special that we we
lived through together
and uh
one of the last times i'd seen him
we played we played in vegas and
you know we just played new years we
were back on track we were playing all
these cool shows
and we played this incredible show and
it was awesome and and uh blink was it
was actually blink reunion and we played
two shows in the city and then am and i
played at night afterwards it was just
so good man and then after the show
you know we talked and i'm like what a
great show and then he's like man
um
he says to me he's like man i just feel
like
doing a [ __ ] ton of drugs and saying
[ __ ] it
and i was like
of course we both feel like that but
we're not gonna do it you know
especially you you're sober
you know you've helped so many of us be
sober and get sober
um and at the time i'm not even smoking
weed anymore i needed i needed maybe a
month of month or two of smoking weed
just to wean myself off those
those toxic drugs that that the hospital
gave us and then that was the last time
i seen him
sadly enough and that was the last words
he said to me
yeah it's brutal
so it's unclear
you know whether it was just a relapse
overdose or whether it was a conscious
choice to you know end his pain yeah we
were in new york and i knew he was going
to be there at the same time we were we
would talk online like i think i said
something on twitter like i said
something like ah so good to be back
with my boys playing shows or whatever
and uh referring to blink
and he hit me and he's like
work everyone could see it too on his
timeline he's like man i knew you liked
playing with them more than me
[ __ ] man like
i i i you know something to the fact
like i hope i hope you don't stop
jamming with me or whatever and i was
like are you insane man like i love what
him and i have were was so strong it was
so there's
it's impossible for you to be more
bonded to another human being yeah
oh my gosh there was nothing
or no one i was closer with than adam
so he was in new york and i remember i
was in a session
i was in a session with a slaughterhouse
um
this rap group and i was working on my
album and he was in new york so i was
supposed to see him and the day before
we were supposed to meet up and i see
one of my managers he's like uh ames not
going to come out tonight i was like why
he's like
dude i think he's going back to rehab
when we go home and i was like why he
does he's sober man he's like he's
strong as nails man so i hit him up
i don't hear back from him you know um
continued to hit him up that night
before i go to sleep don't hear back
from the next morning i have a show in
new york i'm in the studio with
slaughterhouse
and uh we're in the middle of recording
a a song called devil's got ahold of me
and um
someone has me uh
it was a
laptop and it just has
the news that adam you know
it's cunning baffling and powerful
you know it really is
and
all the more heartbreaking when
it's somebody not only that you love
deeply but that's somebody that you
respect for their sobriety you know and
we forget you know i'm a long time sober
you know we forget that as alcoholics as
addicts
that that's our natural state you know
and for some people the pain just
becomes so
overwhelming that it becomes the only
choice you know
i didn't uh
i didn't know am but i have lots of
friends that knew him and the guy was
just beloved you know universally like
beloved
tragic loss
yes it's still difficult because we
don't you know
all we know is
he was he was planning on going to rehab
the following day but i know there's
like a history with people
having one last hooray
you know and and uh
that's this idea that yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna go out one last time and then i'm
gonna clean up and and not appreciating
the fact that like
it doesn't always work out so well yeah
just because
you want to go out doesn't mean that you
can come back you know and it makes you
appreciate and really realize what a
gift sobriety is and how fragile it can
be yeah
yeah and then after you know we found
out everything it was kind of like for
me it was the question of
well
what was it an accident
or
you know was it
well the the fact that he had plans to
go to rehab speaks to
it being you know sort of balancing more
towards accident yeah and some kind of
premeditated it was like was it an
accident or was it the last words you
said to me
which was you know i want to do a bunch
of drugs and say [ __ ] it so for me i
think i struggled with that like when i
was
from i still i still struggle with it a
little bit i wish i knew clearly what it
was
but um
after that it was it was uh
i really it was like final destination
you know it was even more survival's
guilt like am i supposed to be here now
adam's gone
um and adam the strongest human being
who i can't even count on both hands how
many people he got sober our friends you
know or was like a support
group for them including myself
so for me it was just like damn did he
did he purposely do this or was this an
accident and
you know i i beat myself up over it yeah
but clearly he was in pain he had you
know yeah he was in he had some
unresolved pain and
the pain became unbearable enough where
drugs and alcohol or drugs became just
the logical option yeah and i think you
can just leave it at that you know what
happens beyond that
you know you can't
you know he knew
that you loved him
and you can't carry the mantle of
responsibility for what happened
you know yeah you've got you've got to
be able to find a way to free yourself
from that
yeah yeah there was probably about
i was a we were on tour we were on i
think we were in the middle of a tour so
i had a month left of tour and it was
just man it was the hardest we had a
show that i think i cancelled the show
that night
um
but you know for that next month i think
i
probably played every show with my eyes
closed i couldn't even like look up it
was just you know i i knew too he would
want me to go out there and play but uh
at the same time it was just tough
yeah you know
especially it was like
it was just i mean a friend passing is
hard enough
but a friend i went through that with
passing like the only person i could
really you know
speak to about that or kind of see eye
to eye and really kind of get each other
that was
that was a tough one to lose
so how do you start to you know put
together the pieces and heal from this
so that you can be you know integrated
and functional
um
i think it was just
gaining my strength back again
that's what i had to do and like i've
said
a couple times like my kids were the
you know kids
it was it's easy for me to look at them
and say i have to be strong and
and get my strength from them and uh
and set an example
of not letting this take me down or
you know
you know
falling victim to drugs it was really
easy for me to be sober after am passed
away
so that happened pretty quickly after
that yeah you just got you you just got
shocked cleaned oh yeah yeah there was
that was like
it couldn't have been a bigger eye
opener did you just go cold turkey and
do it yourself or did you go to 12 step
or like how did you now the last thing i
did was you know weed was the thing i
was i was just doing
very very little but still doing it from
time to time
and
it must have been maybe like a month
after
am passed i had a
i had this weird thing man i was
recording an album
and i think we were smoking heavily that
day
and and i had this weird lump on my
throat that wouldn't go away
to the point where i was kind of freaked
out
it was like sticking my finger in my
throat i was like what's going on
it's i'm smoking weed it's grown from
the earth you know there's nothing bad i
was giving myself every possible excuse
uh
and i ended up going to the doctor and i
get diagnosed with barrett's esophagus
what is that like pre-cancer yeah
that was it
if there was any question
that was it my i talked to my doctor
who's a he's not my
my normal doctor out here but he's a
friend i i've i've known for years that
lives in san diego i said doc
he's saying i have barrett's esophagus
he's like trav
this is your warning shot stop right now
like you know do whatever he tells you
you cannot reverse pre-cancer like
there's no reversing any damage that's
done to your esophagus
and i was just
that was it for me right it was you know
that was the last you were able to hear
it you had the willingness right you
know what i mean
it's like dude i mean plane crash
you know losing losing am you know
yeah cancer in the throat like come on
dude wake up like the universe is is
trying to gaslight you a little bit here
yeah and sometimes i think before that
with every horrific thing that happened
to me it was like dude this is happening
what's the big deal if i smoke weed you
know it's like
nah and then you know like you said it
all came together it was a plane crash
adam passes away
um
still that one therapist resonating
going like you know if uh
if you know you were to die today would
you be remembered as the man you want to
be i was like
well i'm still
i'm still smoking weed i'm i'm not
completely sober so
that was it for me and and it was uh
it was so great man and i and i felt you
know obviously the first couple weeks
was was weird adapting to not doing
anything just getting rid of bad habits
but
even the people around me man i
the minute you get sober and you stop
doing drugs you stop doing everything
and you're around people who do maybe in
studio environments and
they go to hand you a joint or hand you
a drink or hand you some pills you said
i don't do it no more they're like how'd
you quit and i noticed so many people
were like
why'd you do it you know because they
knew how bad i was and they knew how
everything was in excess for me i mean
psychotic you know i mean i can't
imagine the detox from oxies and you
know coming down from that state that
you were in that must have just been
horrific well that was easy to stop
after the plane crash because in the
hospital i woke up i woke up during
about 10 month surgeries because they
nut they couldn't even medicate me
tolerance was so crazy yeah i'd wake up
in the middle of surgery it was horrible
and i don't know if you
could imagine the pain you feel when you
wake up too like i i would feel and i
would see tons of doctors around me and
i would just swing on them i was like i
was insane like there was
you know i said i said it i think in my
book it was like it was sad that it took
such
a horrific experience like the plane
crash and adam dying for me to get sober
but it did it takes what it takes you
know what yeah like what's it gonna take
to get your attention
yeah and go come on dude there's a
better way to live there's a better plan
for you but you're gonna have to grab
onto it yeah so it's like all these
signals the universe is throwing at you
that you need to course correct
yeah and what's your pain threshold you
know
yeah
and now i mean
now i don't you know i never i never
went to a 12-step program uh-huh so what
has it been like what is it five or six
years yeah it's six years now
i've had great people that are in the
program that have taken me to meetings
and i've gone every once in a while i
usually go i usually go to one on the
anniversary of our plane crash um
or
the anniversary of adam's passing
um because those are days i feel like i
just need some motivation which was
recently right wasn't it just like a
month or two ago
which was seeing like the the
anniversary of am's passing yeah yeah
and then september is the is the plane
crash anniversary so those times i kind
of i kind of go reach out or i just have
a conversation you know like one of the
producer i work with that i do a lot of
production with is sober and he's just
great but honestly
yeah yeah yeah feldi's great man he's
sober he has meetings at his house yeah
it's really cool that guy's a
cornerstone of sobriety yeah he's helped
so many dudes
yeah and and i like once again i have to
say you know being a full-time father i
i get so much joy man that's my favorite
role in life is being a dad you know
my favorite production more than any
album i've produced or
hip-hop song or anything you know it's
like my kids man just
just uh
just being a a role model for them it's
in and being with them has been you know
the happiest thing ever right it's
beautiful yeah and speaking of your kids
i know you gotta you gotta pick them up
in a couple of minutes here yeah which
is like
crazy because there's so many other
things i want to talk we've been talking
for almost two hours and the word vegan
hasn't even come up once i know that's
insane about that yeah but i can't i
can't
segue to that without at least asking
you and then i gotta let you go i know
um
you know now that it's been
a couple years since the crash and and
you have some objectivity on your
sobriety and and that experience
like what do you
you know what do you what do you glean
from that that can be helpful to
somebody because it is an experience
that's so unique i mean there are so few
people on planet earth that have under
you know sort of undergone such a
traumatic experience and survived right
so does that shift your perspective on
how you live your life
oh it shifted everything
um i was very careless before my
accident i would you know
i was a great father but i would still i
mean to me taking tons of pills and
self-medicating myself to get on planes
isn't the most responsible
and you don't fly anymore right no i
don't i don't fly that was the that was
one thing i had to do is is after my
plane crash i said i'll never fly again
um
i'll never put myself in a situation
where i feel like i have to medicate
myself
and
and uh and and take myself away from my
family if the day comes my kids want to
fly i'll fly with them and i'll do
whatever they want they're scared
they're really scared to death of flying
obviously because of what happened to me
and they were really close to little
chris
and che who passed away in the in the
plane
and then they're
they're just as afraid of drugs because
of they saw what happened to adam um
so i t i take a lot from it you know i
live
every day like it's my first and last
and um
and i'm healthier than i've ever been
i'm 41 and i'm healthier now
than i was when i was 20 or when i was
30
or when i was 35 you know it i've i've
i've gotten new addictions
as i let go of my old age fitness is
like a big part of your thing now right
yeah fitness wellness
every time i go into erwin i see you and
you're scoping out like some healthy
food products you know
it's all about the battle ropes and you
know this routine to sort of be your
best self yeah i replaced all the bad
stuff with the good stuff you know um i
eat well i'm vegan gluten free
i've been vegetarian since i was 15
and i became vegan right after my plane
crash
uh
i exercise every day i just traded all
the bad stuff with the good stuff you
know and i i love working out i've
directly
made the connection between working out
and playing the drums and applying you
know
lots of things from both to each other
and it's helped me so much well they
were they're they seem to you know melt
seamlessly i mean the way you drum is
like athletic performance art you know
and i can't imagine you know trying to
do what you do without being in good
physical shape like it is an endurance
sport yeah absolutely an artistic
endurance sport absolutely
so i gotta let you go man such a bummer
i want to talk to you about creativity
i'm obsessed with
unlocking creativity i want to talk to
you more about the vegan stuff and your
daily routines and all this stuff but i
do have to let you go you've been very
generous with your time so maybe i can
honor who'd wink you to come back and we
could talk a little bit more about that
stuff that would be awesome all right
man so thanks so much dude that was yeah
really oh man i appreciate your openness
and and
you know honesty talking about some
difficult stuff of course yeah very cool
my pleasure so uh if you're digging on
travis the best way to connect with him
is probably your website
travisbarker.com at travisbarker
on all the internet sites yeah yeah
instagram just travis parker the book
can i say uh which i still have to read
i got to pick that up this interview
came together pretty quickly so i didn't
have a chance to read it but i'm looking
forward to digging into it cool so pick
that up and uh you have any shows coming
up soon or any dates
um we are heading over to europe for the
summer oh wow so yeah we'll be out there
in europe and i have with blank yeah
with blink cool yeah
together again with the new album and
all that kind of stuff yeah it's been
amazing i think i don't know where we
got nominated for a grammy so we'll see
i think they're still announcing who's
performing so yeah who knows uh-huh
very cool man yeah awesome and you just
did kimmel the other night right yeah
yeah and you did uh you did you had some
crazy show uh
new years with um steve aoki right well
no i wasn't just you solo yeah i have a
dj drum routine um you know me being
around like i played with so many great
djs well of course adam dj
and then after he passed me and a-track
did right uh a routine together than me
billboard yes
yeah so i've been surrounded with
the best djs you know ever and um and
i've always loved djing and scratching
so i actually have a routine and i have
a residency in vegas so oh yeah yeah so
back to the entrepreneurial kind of yeah
your career new year's as a drummer who
does that
that you know that's what's always been
my thing is like how do i how do you how
do i keep creating keep evolving and
keep things interesting for myself and
do what i love and that's
that's one of them you know i'm taking
like what you know being inspired by
what am and i started and just the
evolution of that
so great talking about it yeah man you
too cool
peace thank you please
[Music]
you